all right so for more on this let's uh
bring in CBS news reporter Camila
Montoya Galvez really good to see you we
talked a little bit about this when the
news broke yesterday that these uh
troops are going to be heading to the
Border title 42 is ending soon
but why is there an expectation that
there will be a surge in migrants are we
already seeing a surge in anticipation
of this happening
good morning Anne-Marie just to give our
viewers some context title 42 it's this
unprecedented public health authority
dating back to the Trump Administration
who invoked this measure at the outset
of the kova 19 pandemic that has allowed
U.S border officials to rapidly expel
hundreds of thousands of migrants and
Asylum Seekers back to Mexico or to
their home countries without letting
them seek Asylum and that is normally a
requirement under U.S Asylum law this
policy is set to end next week with the
expiration of the National Public Health
Emergency over covid and the reason that
border officials expect to see an
increase in migration once this policy
ends Anne-Marie is because all migrants
who reach us soil after title 42 is
lifted will need to be processed and
those who ask for Asylum will need to be
interviewed or given the chance to make
a case in front of a judge that takes
time and more resources and the tension
capacity border officials are expecting
as many as 10 thousand migrants to enter
U.S border custody each day after next
week Anne-Marie and the number of people
coming has already increased in the
lead-up to this policy change U.S border
officials are recording an average of
more than 7 000 migrant apprehensions in
recent days so each day hence the need
for 1500 troops on the border they're
really going to be doing a lot of
administrative work taking the weight
off of the border patrol people
that's right we have to underscore yet
again Anne-Marie that these service
members will not process or stop and
detain migrants and Asylum Seekers that
is in accordance to long-standing
practice and also federal law that
generally bars the military from
engaging in civilian law enforcement
duties such as detaining migrants and
deporting them so they are strictly
there to perform operational and
administrative duties such as data entry
and transportation to support border
patrol this is an effort Anne-Marie to
relieve some of the pressure on Border
officials so they can apprehend migrants
detain them and interview them that is
the purpose behind this operation it is
also very important to note that the US
has deployed active duty troops and
Reserve units to the U.S Mexico border
since 2006 under Democratic and
Republican administrations I assume you
remember Anne-Marie that this became a
national issue during the Trump
Administration which deployed thousands
of troops to the Border as part of that
broader Crackdown on illegal migration
including to instruct them to paint
border barriers so this is an issue that
dates back more than a decade it
certainly does and I'm sure it'll be one
of the top issues campaign 2024.
um Camila thank you very much
thanks Emery